classes started again officially at
marys two days ago but for me they
started yesterday I've got tuesday
friday classes on there on campus just
those days out of the week and it was
very nice returning this is my third
year teaching at marist and i was gonna
shoot a video yesterday specifically
about this but got tied up with too many
things so I'm shooting one about it
today made me think about quite a few
things one of the the best sets of
experiences that I had and this is sort
of a sign of how long I've been there
now there's kind of a longevity involved
in this is that I ran into five former
students all of whom I I enjoyed having
in my classes whose papers were quite
often at least better than average to
sometimes spectacular and two of them
were in my my ethics class that I taught
in the afternoon and they were students
who had formerly had in one or another
of my intro to philosophy classes one
was a guy who I had my very first
semester at marist when I taught in the
very basement the bowels of Donna Lee
Hall in this this one classroom that
that's not particularly well set up and
it was very nice to have him in the
class he had actually petitioned me over
and over again to try to get an override
and they were there was a there's a
policy in place that keeps students from
getting those too easily because they
want to keep class sizes fairly small
and I I told the guy you know just keep
trying just keep trying and sure enough
he got in when I asked him what he
actually had to do for for the override
he said I can't tell you but I'm very
academic in the class I've got another
student who is in my intro to philosophy
class last semester who very very bright
rights excellent papers inquisitive mind
talks a lot in class i'm very happy to
have her as well they're going to be
sort of leven for the the bread of that
that ethics class and then i saw
one of my students from my ethics class
last semester when I was at the library
had to get my computer set up so that I
can actually use it on marist campus
they have to put all sorts of software
on at their very security-conscious
there and so there was you know there
they relocated the IT people who do that
to the library so that they could handle
all the freshmen in flux and I saw this
former student of mine who wrote the
extraordinarily good papers talked a lot
in class and the ethics class usually it
was quite on point and who I very much
enjoyed catching up with and she was
there with with a friend of hers and we
talked a little buff majors and what
what they're studying now I ran into
another student going going out of the
library a student who had had in to two
semesters before in ethics class and
caught up with her a little bit in
passing and then as I was coming through
one of the buildings you know on my way
to to my car I ran into yet another
student a guy who I spent a lot of time
with talking after class in part because
we have you know the military connection
in common I'm of that and he he's in
ROTC and but he's also prior service
which you know and in my view actually
makes for the best of officers I would
much rather have somebody over me who's
actually been an enlisted man himself
rather than just proceeded up through
the ranks so into the gentleman officer
corps we have in any way he and I have
you know talked quite a bit about all
sorts of issues ranging from ethics to
to military life to you know what went
on in high school all sorts of
interesting things and so I had some
time on my hands that I said well let's
go and get something cool to drink and
sit down for a while and catch up so we
did that and that was really nice I
always enjoyed reconnecting with these
students long after the the classes are
finished in part because I get to see
what they actually
member door we're struck by or found
application for from the classes but
also because i often form you know kind
of uh I wouldn't say deep friendships
necessarily with all my students but I
form some sort of personal bond in part
because I I asked them to do so much
personal writing over the course of the
semester I get to know them quite well
and I give them feedback you know I'm
the papers that they write in the course
of my classes that kind of sometimes
they respond to you know I talk with him
after class yeah there's something
really nice about that so that was a
quite enjoyable aspect of my day
yesterday I had two classes in the
morning i had my intro to philosophy
class which is now called philosophical
perspectives but for all practical
purposes that means the same thing as
intro philosophy and this semester i
have centered it on the theme of love
friendship and desire so we're reading
mostly ancient and medieval texts a few
modern texts that that not only
introduced them to the history of
philosophy in general and you know big
themes in metaphysics or epistemology or
ethics or philosophy of human nature but
to these you know analyses and
descriptions and problems dealing with
these intensely personal aspects of
human human existence when I went
through and I started thinking about the
reading list that I wanted to do you
know there's always this temptation to
try to cram in way too much which is a
beginner's mistaken in designing classes
and in these survey classes taught to
non majors you really can't overwhelm
them with with too much material or else
none of it is going to to make any sense
to them so what I did is I focused
mainly on these ancient and medieval
thinkers and I had to leave out a lot of
people who I originally wanted to talk
about like you know Bernard of Clairvaux
you know he's got a lot of interesting
things to say about love but we just
couldn't fit a min so if we want to do
Thomas Aquinas we can't do we can't do
Bernard this time
want to do Cicero we can't do Seneca
this time we want to do Plato's
symposium where we can't do the Phaedrus
you know you have to make little cuts so
next semester i'm going to teach the
same class of course different students
but we're also going to focus it on this
same grand theme of love friendship and
desire and explore different you know
philosophical approaches to them and
we'll hit some of the ancient thinkers
who we didn't get to medieval fingers
that will focus it more on on modern
thinkers so in any case I you know did
my typical run through which is welcome
everybody in take roll and then then
spend a lot of time going over the
syllabus and you know the particular you
know details of certain things like what
constitutes a full page of writing you
know stuff that's not that that
interesting and then I show them the I
learned site I learned is our course
management system you know if you're at
a different University you might have
blackboard or Moodle or something like
that I learned is a variant of Sakai and
I create entire online learning
environments using the course management
system which was part of why it was so
easy for me to switch type to online
teaching you know outside of the normal
semester in the summer and in the winter
Ramires because i already had all these
great things put into i learn for my
ethics classes so for an intro class
every semester I redesign things there
are some things I retain you know
descriptions of what philosophy is or
the the breakdowns and philosophy but
but every semester what I'm doing new
material you may have seen some of the
lecture videos from the intro to
philosophy classes I have that and but I
also supply them with handouts and
entire lessons you know coming covering
basic ideas all of it is loaded into the
course management system all the
assignments are carried out in there and
I do actually have a lot of assignments
in my class as I tend to every week
there's something that they have to
write
and it's usually at least a page page
and a half then there's some larger
papers over the course of the semester
as well and you know I need them to be
thinking about this stuff and if they're
not writing about it they're not going
to do the sort of deep thinking that I
want them to do so you know we cover all
those sorts of things and I show them
here's where you find this and here's
where you get the course tax I don't
actually use a textbook the ilearn site
itself is the textbook and I've got
links to PDF files in which I've got
Plato's symposium or Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics book book 89
everything is provided to them
essentially for free what she goes
perfectly fine they pay a ton of money
to go to this place so why should i
burden them like a lot of their other
classes are doing with a hundred dollars
in textbooks or even more when I can you
know I can do this with some effort on
my part and give it to them for free and
give them something that they won't sell
back something that they'll actually
hold on to and keep on their tablet or
their computer so you know the intro
class is pretty good it's it's very big
there's 30 students registered for the
class because the freshman class turned
out to be a little bit larger than
they'd expected at marys about a hundred
extra students so they had to find
places for them and fortunately not
everybody showed up I think about 28
students showed up which is good because
we only had 29 seats in the room so
we'll see what happens with that usually
there's a few people who drop but it
sounds like a pretty good crop of
students usually mayoral students are
there a little bit passive as as
freshmen in part because many of them
have gone to middle schools and high
schools where they're not encouraged to
ask a lot of questions there's a lot of
teaching to the test and just shut up so
we can get through this kind of kind of
thing plus a lot of them are from fairly
traditional homes where it's nice to
note education is held in some respect
that the idea is you know the teachers
there to teach so shut up and listen
and we want to try to break them of that
a bit in philosophy it's tough to do in
a class with 30 students right because
not everybody can talk at the same time
and not everybody's as comfortable with
it and it is difficult material and
students are often quite intimidated a
lot of them get a chance to to to talk
and part through the papers that I have
them right because they have them think
about the basic ideas and then apply
them within the scope of their own life
and experiences and do some reflection
as well as doing close readings of the
things so you know I'm the whole good
crop of students to work with generally
marys students when I give them work to
do they will do it they may not always
understand exactly what I'm asking for
the first time around but they you know
they have a good work ethic and that is
that makes all the difference in the
world when here when you're teaching
this sort of material so that was the
morning class and then you know first
day coming back it's always reconnect
with with colleagues and that's exactly
what I did I went down the hall one you
know one Hall in our building and then
once you know off to the next floor
where my adjunct office is and came down
the hall and chatted with people and
found out what they'd done over the
summer and what they were up to now and
and conveyed greetings and receive
greetings you know and and all that sort
of thing and that was nice check to see
whether I'm going to still be doing a
talk later later this fall for the
Medieval and Renaissance Studies speaker
series and the answer appears to be yes
at this point so that's good of a video
about that when I actually do the talk
and then so another colleague in the
adjunct office writing colleague talked
with him for a while you know about the
writing program and what they're going
through and what the crop of freshmen
look like you know we always kind of its
that quite gossip it's more talking
shocked that we the instructors do
across the curriculum with each other
that's part of what goes on at a
university that's part of what makes it
into a community of inquiry
you know university isn't just a bunch
of people showing up teaching their
classes and then getting hell out of
there it's people who you know come to a
place where learning is supposed to
occur and they're actually interested in
whether it is occurring how do you how
do you determine whether it's occurring
how do you how do you make sure that
it's actually going to happen how do you
connect it up with what your other
colleagues are doing you know sometimes
we get into arguments with each other or
you know disagree about whether they
should read this text or not but for the
most part is pretty genial there or at
least it is for me yeah and then I had
my afternoon class which was the ethics
class early in the afternoon and that
was you know in the same building where
I've taught for quite a while same
building where my offices and there were
about 25 students who showed up for that
I think I have 27 on the books and you
know we went over the same sort of stuff
as we do for the intro class here's the
syllabus you know what are your papers
going to be like what can you expect
which my grading policies what if you
have a late assignment all that sort of
stuff and I was able to get them to be
you know engaged when we were talking
about you know like the course goals and
why we're doing this why writing matters
for example and you know why they need
to take the class what they're hopefully
going to get out of it do the same thing
with showing them the the online
learning environment for ethics I'm
really recycling what I've done over the
last couple well the last couple years
the last seven or eight terms since I
teach it so often you know I go over the
same material I change it up a little
bit like this semester for example we're
not going to Nietzsche is not going to
be a required reading which usually I
would couple with Plato's Republic with
ones who talked about the might makes
right theory I'll still have it in there
is a supplemental reading if they
but we are gonna add Plato's Republic
book 9 where he because I realized when
we do the play doh you know book for
they they do get you know the four
cardinal virtues but they don't they
don't have enough to make sense of it we
need another class day where we talk
about the appetites and pleasures and
and you know states of character and
that sort of thing so book nine is a
good book night as the book about how
people screw up and book nine is a good
good good book for that so I added some
things i subtracted some things but for
the most part it's it's fairly similar
to what we had before we're not doing
hobbes at all I've got another mcintyre
reading in place with some of the Thomas
Aquinas but in any case I got things set
up well we're they know what their first
reading is it's McIntyre's playing
persons in moral philosophy which is a
text that I particularly like to start
things off with because he situates did
you know the very abstract moral theory
stuff in these ancient and medieval and
modern texts in the context of ordinary
people's lives he says everybody has to
do moral philosophy to some degree
you're either going to do it badly
you're gonna do it well you're either
going to do it unconsciously you're
going to do it consciously so let's
let's actually think about what we're
doing let's think about these these big
questions and how you focus in on how
they fit into your individual life and
how you see everybody else around you
doing the same so you know I gave them a
little bit of a rundown about that I had
some interesting questions some people
asked about you know how hard are these
texts gonna be is this going to connect
up with other classes that I've had they
usually have a pretty varied experience
the ethics class is the second
philosophy class that they take at
marist but it's usually quite a bit
after they took their intro to
philosophy class and intro to philosophy
there is a core to it but it can be
taught in a lot of different ways so I
can't count on them having necessarily
had exposure to
to Aristotle or can't aura Thomas
Aquinas and I certainly can't I can't
count on them actually having remembered
what was what was taught in those those
classes because it could be you know
several semesters since they been in
there so you know we have to sort of
begin from the ground up and it's one of
these classes that everybody has to take
regardless of their major usually I
don't have a single philosophy major in
my ethics class I'm teaching to
communications and business and fashion
merchandising and and sociology and you
know special ed you know who knows what
what what majors are going to be and
it's up to me as the instructor to find
ways to make this material relate to
what they're doing of criminal justice
is another big major too so I try to
come up with lots of good examples that
they can they can they can all
understand and maybe it doesn't apply
directly to their major but they can at
least appreciate how it would fit into
something that they they do think about
so all told it looks like it's going to
be a pretty good semester I've got quite
a few you know projects outside of class
lined up for myself but i'll talk more
about that i think in my my next you
know monthly update that I do on my
channel regularly now and I just wanted
to I'm so happy about my my day
yesterday and how it went going back to
marys again it's my third year so this
is my second time coming back I just
wanted to share that with my my viewers
this may interest some of you this may
not interest some of you I know that
some of you are people who like watching
the videos because you you know you
couldn't afford to go to college or it
just didn't work out you know the way
your work life went or personal life
went and you watch these kinds of videos
mine and other people's in part to try
to have something like a university
education
I know that some of you watching this or
students either at marist or at other
other colleges I know that some of you
might be friends of mine from from way
back or something like that so I wanted
to share something at least for me a
kind of personal but also that might
give you you know peel back the veil a
little bit and show you what it's like
for a college professor coming back to
teach at their their institution no I
think it's not completely my institution
cuz I I'm an adjunct so I don't have the
same kind of steak that a full-time
faculty member would have but but i have
come to feel kind of a sense of
belonging of being part of a community
certainly with my colleagues certainly
with my my students and with you know
quite a few of the staff that i deal
with as well in IT in the library
there's a real sense of community there
and that's something that as a scholar
as a instructor as an academic i have to
say i'm finding more and more congenial
something more and more even necessary
in in my own life nobody wants to be an
island off entirely on their own or at
least some people do but you know that's
that's not that's not really a full life
for an academic a full life I think
includes at the very least having some
people that you can you can talk with
not necessarily teach but at least just
talk with and bounce ideas off of who
actually care about what you're talking
about and find some intrinsic value in
it maybe not at all of it but but at
least they're open to the possibility
that what you're doing actually has some
some value it's a lot easier to sustain
one's own endeavors when it's there's a
reflection going on when there's a
recognition a mutual recognition
both sides so it's starting to get a
little rambling I'm going to cut it off
here because I think that's quite quite
enough for this video